let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 our first caller will be from the 9 1
6 area code listen for your area code
because you won't hear anything in
particular when we go to you but our
next callers from 9 1 6 who's this
hi David this is Anthony a call from
California I actually have two questions
first one is I have a lot of difficulty
talking to people who are right-wing or
Trump supporters or really set in their
ways you know I have a lot of family and
friends even out here in California who
are incredibly entrenched in their
beliefs and regardless of evidence or
any kind of debate that we have with
each other even if we love and care
about each other it goes nowhere
it's nothing and it is it is probably
one of the most frustrating things
because it's it's just this blatant
ignorance that you just can't get past
so what he's destined part of it the
question part is how how do you deal
with these kinds of relationships with
these people who have these terrible
views but they're involved in your daily
lives
yeah you've just got to make a decision
as to whether number one you want to
keep them in your daily life or not
assuming that you do because they're
people you know and care about and and
presumably have a role in your life you
have to sort of agree that you're not
going to talk about politics that's the
sad reality but if the idea is just to
be able to coexist in some more
reasonable way you basically have to
take the don't talk politics at
Thanksgiving thing that some families
have to do and apply it to your
year-round life that's the only thing I
can think of because you're already
experiencing the the frustrations and
difficulties of it I don't know what
other possibility there is and the
second question would be what
ramifications do you foresee if the
Democrats don't do well this November oh
you'll see an even more emboldened Trump
and a hyper it'll be seen as a
and eight for Republicans to continue
passing all sorts of crazy crazy stuff
and that would be a disaster
particularly because in the midterms
typically you see the party that doesn't
control the White House pick up seats so
I'm not even going to go there beyond
that initial comment because it would be
such a total unmitigated disaster that
that that is very scary and then he
thank you so much for the call I really
appreciate it